lips and Rob met when they were 13 14  years old and they decided to rock  together forever and literally as we sit  here today it's 50 years later they're  65 and they're still doing it I love  music that's why I do it generally you  you're doing it because you really love  to do this you you're driven to do it  I'm dripping my thing that drives me  most is I've got to make I gotta put  together a song that's that's going to  satisfy this [ __ ] I mean I'm not  going to quit on myself yeah what for  like I can't I can't cope with that  notion yeah why didn't you quit hey you  quit what you hate right not what you  love not what you love being  unsuccessful would be something okay  they did an album and they don't exist  anymore for 20 30 years no we do we did  an album every couple years generally  generally speaking if you're real  artists you should be here till you till  you're pushing up daisies